all right Fox news headline DeSantis
calls Florida land of sanity and slams
Biden policies and his inaugural address
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis on Tuesday
praise the Sunshine State as the land of
liberty and land of Sanity while
slamming the floundering Federal
establishment in Washington DC the bite
Administration and laying out his
policies for the months and years ahead
as he was sworn in for a second term the
santis who's considered a likely GOP
2024 presidential Contender delivered
his inaugural address on the steps of
the state's capital in Tallahassee on
Tuesday after a decisive 19-point
re-election Victory now it was a great
speech and all and I think it's uh
it's worth a very good speech at least
worth watching but this was the best
part here's just a 20 second clip
and this may not seem very remarkable to
you what he says here but this to me was
my favorite part of his speech listen to
this
Florida must always be a great place to
raise a family we will enact more
family-friendly policies to make it
easier to raise children and we will
defend our children against those who
seek to Rob them of their innocence
there you go very simple like I said
doesn't appear to be anything
revolutionary there
um and there isn't
but this should be the Republican
party's platform going into 2024.
and this is if you want to know what my
political ideology is at this point
that's it well you just heard there
that's that's the whole thing
protect families protect children
there you go
uh that's what that's it that's the
fundamental political platform and
that's what every Republican ought to be
talking about
and if the term conservatism means
anything it ought to be conserving that
I mean most fundamentally as I always
talk about it's conserving basic truth
it's also conserving and protecting the
family and uh and you know and this the
safety and innocence of children
that should be
the marching orders
and not only is that the right
you know the right platform and the
right mission
and and what needs to be done
but it's also a winning political
message
forget about what you've heard from
squishy establishment Republicans for
years and years
who still to this day
you know they will go down with the ship
claiming that all anybody cares about is
their wallet and the financial bottom
line and so just talk about tax cuts and
all of that that's all anything anybody
cares about
that's not true people care about money
they care about their financial
well-being of course they do we all do
but they care about those things
primarily because of how that affects
the the uh safety and stability of their
families and their children
because even more basic than the
financial concern is that concern about
your family about your kids this is what
people
this is why I always say you know you
gotta you gotta think about what do
people wake up in the morning thinking
about
okay they don't wake up in the morning
thinking about tax cuts nobody does
um if you're a parent you wake up in the
morning and you're thinking about your
kids you're thinking about your family
you're thinking about your spouse like
that's that's the first thoughts in your
mind
and politically if you're speaking to
that if you're speaking to forget about
the kitchen table issues I'm talking
about before you even get to the kitchen
table okay before you sit down and catch
a table for breakfast what are the
things that you're thinking about
and it's that
and politically if you're speaking to
those issues
um then that's that is going to be a
winner every time for almost everybody
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]